a coup attempt is underway in the West
African nation of Niger Witnesses report
that military vehicles have been
blocking the entrance to Muhammad
bazoom's presidential Palace the
President says members of the
presidential guard are holding him
inside the palace access to Ministries
next to the Palace had also been blocked
as bringing Ahmed Idris was following
developments from Abuja in neighboring
Nigeria Ahmed what have you been able to
gather on this
well basically what we are hearing from
near me is that military activity has
been noticed on the outskirts of the
city where some of these military
Barracks have been set up and there was
a statement calling on all loyal troops
to move in and quell the disturbance and
some reports suggest that there's been
some skirmishes around the national
television station but that has not been
fully confirmed yes the president is
still being held by the presidential
guard who took him earlier this morning
from his res in his residence and kept
him captive and his family now the
economic community of West African State
Echoes has issued a strong statement
condemning the core attempt saying that
they will not accept any
unconstitutional mean a change of power
in Missouri public and they're calling
on the cool protons those who are trying
to execute the coup to return to their
battle Center under themselves thank you
very much I'll let you and your team
news gather and if something significant
happens you'll let us know meanwhile
I'll go to Charles Stratford in Dakar
Charles you're at the ecowas summit
that's the economic community of West
African States what are they saying are
you learning anything there
well certainly there has been a
statement put out by ecos already as you
heard Ahmed detail there ecowas which is
the the reasonable body responsible for
security
across this region condemning this
seemingly this attempted coup in the
most vigorous way in their words they
were calling for All actors involved to
release the president and who of course
was democratically elected in
2021 there's also been a statement put
out by the African Union
calling on what they describes as the
treasonous soldiers to stop immediately
so simply a very worrying situation in
the in the Amy in in this year and of
course in the context of the entire
region suffering so many military coups
in recent years according to our
estimates here we've calculated it would
be the sixth coup if indeed this is a
coup and a successful one it would be
the sixth one in West Africa in in
recent years so um a great concern
especially because Niger is so pivotal
plays such a pivotal role in security
operations anti-terror operations across
the region
um most notably not only in Niger but in
places like uh in Mali and Burkina Faso
because French forces have been rebased
there having had to be moved out of Mali
um in in recent months as well um so it
has huge security implications there's a
a very worrying worrying news from
another West African State this morning
all right Charles Stratford in Dakar
thank you very much same thing as ahmeda
let you go and as you find out more on
what's happening on the ground in Niger
we'll be cutting back to you thank you
Charles
Emmanuel quezzi eineng is the director
of The Faculty of academic Affairs and
research at the Kofi Annan International
peacekeeping training center and he
explains why West African nations are
constantly under Coupe threats
Niger has been fairly unstable since
1960 having four successful coup d'etats
and several unsuccessful schools located
within just about the epicenter of the
violence in this island
so the on balance
the president Mahmoud bazoom and his
government seem to be facing a very
appeal task but I think it's very
important
um that the signals from the
International Community are consistent
and I think here
though after some trade-offs deepening
democracy
um much more inclusive set of inclusive
Economic Development processes and then
support for the government to be able
to deliver very credible fight to the
violent extremists in Nigeria the
population is almost in increasing by 40
50 percent almost every five years or so
that places
immense pressures on any government
ability to create jobs to provide
education to provide Health to provide
housing but there must be a balance
around this and there must be a
conversation as to how governments that
are under economic Restraint of limited
resources are able to explain to their
populations what the challenges are an
ability to fight corruption that has
been a major challenge for West Africa's
democracies and that almost consistently
almost legitimizes
the military's desire to end a intervene
corruption is the big elephant in the
room
Plus
the fights against violent extremists
this is a challenge that almost to our
West African governments are facing